this is Startalk let's move on to
Brandon Wow God you guys you can't see
Chuck's face but he's a back he is taken
aback he has been taken okay Brandon
Brandon this better be good I got a
feeling it is agghhhh agghhhhh Camaron
Brandon a cog camera a camera a Kamran
okay I bring stir I think I got it
Brandon says hey bill considering you've
been on both sides of the argument on
GMOs can you in your opinion I don't
know whose else opinion you would do I'm
very good at mine yeah list the most
beneficial and non beneficial reasons
for GMOs oh nice one uh mister uh oh he
misspelled phonetically here ugh Cameron
a comer and so uh mister uh Cameron
here's the deal
he wants you to play your own devil's
advocate yeah good and bad yeah so as I
say the good ladies and gentlemen Bill
Nye pro and con the good side is we get
more yield per hectare or acre okay one
so in other words we have less impactful
farming in other words we affect the
ecosystem less because we'll produce
more food on less land that's the upside
of genetically - one for we're using
biology to fight pests and diseases
rather than chemistry that's - for so
that's good the unintended consequence
the classic one is either the things you
don't know - not to go all misguided
military principle of policy on you but
the unknowns the known unknown known
unknown like we don't know what you're
going to do but the one that everybody
has observed is the monarch butterflies
where we have reduced their population
ninety percent not as a consequence
exactly of raising genetically modified
food but by using this extraordinarily
effective
herbicide that has killed the milk
flowers or milk weeds which nourish the
Monarchs so an unintended consequence
there and so are there
that you don't know are there other
insects and pollinators that you
affected accidentally by messing up
their food source and the other
unintended consequence not a necessary
one is by monoculture farming ignore
must rattle type of plant make it very
hard for beep bees as pollinators to get
the job done they got to go out there do
that one crop then there's nothing to do
and somebody puts them back in a box and
puts them on a truck and takes them to a
different crop and they just get beaten
up they and handle it but this is not
necessarily coming home stressed out
they do they are babe god what a day I
gotta tell you you should have seen it
except eyes are gone it's a girl voice
oh that is correct cuz all the bees of
female all the ones that go to work is
right so good go ahead do it again honey
I just can't believe the day I had I'm
telling you this is just awful those the
our size is high man otra ves babe yes
alright Chuck nice is a four wing fly
all right so all right the unintended
consequences are things like the monarch
butterflies and this monocultural
farming which affects the pollinators
and our whole agriculture system so
these are things that are avoidable
gotcha so it's good and bad but it's
manageable and I think it's just a
necessary consequence when you're going
to have 7.2 billion people become nine
point two billion people you're going to
have to do something to feed them and
indeed we all prefer the texture taste
and nutrients from nominally hybridized
crops over the last 10,000 years and
this modern biotechnological way of
modifying it's just the next thing
humans are doing gotcha so alright that
was great to see you argue both sides
there and basically the biggest problem
is the unknowns and I said that's what
you want to avoid but you can't do it
until you do it you can't know until you
do it but humans have been doing this
for centuries you know we tried this
plant it doesn't work so we try that
plant and so the claim is leave me I've
been there so the claim is that you do
it very carefully right so for those of
you tuned in to our previous episode I
talked about these guys are able to
ask these people are able to assay or
sequence genes literally ten million
times faster now than they could even a
decade ago fantastic it's amazing
ten million times and the reason is
people have invested in the technical
engineers who have developed the
technology worked really hard on it
because there's so much to be so much
gain to be had and everybody prefers
delicious corn to not delicious corn
everybody prefers delicious apples or
good tasting apples not to single out a
particular flavor I do like the Red
Delicious I'm a Honey Crisp man so I'm
down with honey Chris yeah but I died
we'll remind everybody there's two
things about Red Delicious that I really
like which are there red okay and
they're delicious yes I like my galas
Laila's are okay I like the braver yeah
the braeburns are right - I'm not a big
Granny Smith guy but I'll choke it down
so anyways with that said when it comes
to Jake Lee modified food or crops we
iced have to be diligent okay so here's
the deal wires regulation whoa yeah see
now you lost me man I'm a Republican I'm
all against the regulation of any kind
sorry okay okay so I'll watch for you
when the lights red exactly this is
Startalk